this guy is an operator  and operators are intimidating  you know why operators are intimidating  because operators don't just say things  to say them biden will say things to get  elected  every 90 of people that are running for  office they'll say whatever they can to  get elected because the history is about  what it's about who got elected right  every once in a while you find a person  that you know how they say i'm gonna  kick your ass they're actually gonna  kick your ass  okay  those types of people are very scary so  to the only thing that he  made a point that makes you think is the  following  so  let's just say  you know how different are trump and  desantis  if they're pushing this hard  for trump  to be eliminated because they want to  indict him so he can't run  what they're really saying is we would  much rather face off desantis than face  off right